because you can also do
translation now on the audio right um
like subtitles so it would be both uh
transcription and translation that's
right
i wanted to test the system to see how
good it is to see like how how uh
will is russian supported i think so
yeah
it'd be interesting to try it out i mean
one of the now it's only in like the one
direction right so you start with
english and then you can have subtitles
in russian
not really not really the other way got
it because it's i'm
i'm deeply curious about this i'm one
kovit opens up a little bit when the
economy when the world opens up a little
bit
you want to build your brand in russia
no i don't
first of all i'm allergic to the word
brand that's
i'm definitely not building uh any
brands in russia nice but i'm going to
paris
to talk to the uh translators of
dostoyevsky and tolstoy
there's this famous couple that does
translation
and you know i'm more and more thinking
of how is it possible to have a
conversation with a russian speaker
because i have just some number of
famous russian speakers that i'm
interested in talking to and
my russian is not strong enough to be
witty and funny i'm already
an idiot in english i'm an extra level
of like
awkward idiot in russian but i can
understand it
right and i also like to wonder how can
i create a compelling
english russian experience for an
english speaker like if i
there's a guy named pearlman who's a
mathematician
who uh obviously doesn't speak any
english
so i would probably incorporate like
a russian translator into the picture
and then it would be like a
not to use a weird term but like a three
like a three
three person thing where it's like a
dance of where
like i understand it one way they don't
understand the other way
but i'll be asking questions in english
i don't know i don't know the right way
complicated it's complicated but i feel
like it's worth the effort for certain
kinds of
people one of whom i'm confident of
vladimir putin i'm for sure
talking to i really want to make it
happen because i think i could do a good
job with it
but the the right you know understanding
the fundamentals of translation
is something i'm really interested in so
that's why i'm starting with um
the actual translators of like russian
literature because they understand the
nuance and the beauty of the language
how it goes back and forth but i also
want to see like in speech
how can we do it in real time so that's
that's like a little bit of a
baby project that i hope to push forward
but anyway it's a challenging thing so
just to share my dad um actually does
translation
um not not professional he's a uh he
writes poetry
that was kind of always his uh
not a hobby but he's uh he you know he
had a job like a day job but his passion
was always writing poetry
and when we get to america and like he
started also translating
first he was translating english poetry
to russia and now he also like goes the
other
the other way you kind of gain some
small fame in that world anyways because
uh
recently this poet like lewis clark i
don't know if you
know i've so american poet um she was
awarded the nobel prize for literature
and so my dad had translated one of her
books of poetry into russian and he was
like
one of the few so he kind of like they
asked him and
gave an interview to radius if you know
what that is and
he kind of talked about some of the
intricacies of translating poetry so
that's like an extra level of difficulty
right because
translating poetry is even more
challenging than yeah translating just
you know it's interviews do you remember
any any experiences and challenges to
having to do the translation that that
stick out to like something he's talked
about
i mean a lot of it i think is word
choice right it's the way russian is
structured is first all quite different
than um english is structured right just
there's inflections in russian and
genders and they don't exist in english
one of the reasons actually why machine
translation is quite difficult for
english to russian and russian to
english because there's such different
languages
but then english has like a huge number
of words um
many more than russian actually i think
so it's often difficult to find the
right word
to not convey the same emotional meaning
yeah russian language they play with
words much more
you